♪ ♪
>> THEY WANT TO MAKE A DEAL,
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Mike: PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WITH AN
UNANNOUNCED VISIT TO AFGHANISTAN
TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE
COME A LONG WAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES ON THIS HOLIDAY.
ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE BIG
PICTURE FOR AFGHANISTAN.
WITH THAT, LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER,"
WHITE HOUSE REPORTER FOR THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, AND DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST LESLIE MARSHALL.
YOUR THOUGHTS AND THE PRESIDENT
TURNING UP IN AFGHANISTAN TODAY?
>> CRITICAL MOMENT FOR THE PEACE
DEAL IN AFGHANISTAN THAT HAS
LONG ELUDED THE UNITED STATES,
THE PRESIDENT WANTS FEWER TROOPS
THERE, THERE ARE ABOUT 12 OR
13,000 TROOPS, HE WANTS IT DOWN
TO ABOUT 8,000, YOU CAN'T DO
THAT IF THERE IS NO PEACE DEAL
AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT, IT WAS CALLED OFF
WHEN THAT EXPLOSION KILLED AN
AMERICAN SOLDIER, THE PRESIDENT
SAID FORGET IT, NO MORE TALKS.
NOW HE'S SAYING LET'S START
AGAIN, LET'S START THIS UP.
IT'S STILL A REAL LONG ROAD TO
GET FROM JUST TALKING TO
AMERICAN TROOPS LEAVING.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
BECOMING AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
IF ALL THE TROOPS LEAVE, THE
TERROR THREAT THERE WILL BUILD
AGAIN, POTENTIALLY THREATENING
THE UNITED STATES.
IT SEEMS TO ME FROM LISTENING TO
HIM TODAY HE DID MAKE THIS
COMMENT ABOUT TOTAL VICTORY
WHICH I DON'T THINK ANYONE
THINKS IS POSSIBLE NOW BUT HE
DID TALK ABOUT THE IDEA IF WE
GET A DEAL FINE, IF WE DON'T,
THAT'S FINE.
THAT MEANS THAT TROOPS ARE GOING
TO STAY THERE AND THAT'S THE
MESSAGE I GOT FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Mike: YOU COVERED THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF VISITING THE TROOPS IN THE
HOLIDAY?
>> THE CLOAK AND DAGGER IS COOL,
THE PRESIDENT VISITING THIS
COUNTRY AND FLYING INTO
AFGHANISTAN AND NO ONE'S GOING
TO KNOW ABOUT IT?
IT HAPPENED THAT WAY WHICH IS
ALWAYS KIND OF COOL HOW THESE
VISITS COME DOWN.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS IS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS, PARTICULARLY
GOING INTO 2020, IF YOU CAN GET
SOME SORT OF PEACE DEAL AND
START WORKING TOWARDS A DRAW
DOWN, THAT IS THE SORT OF
BUMPER STICKER FOREIGN POLICY
MOMENT THAT HE NEEDS AS HE IS
TOWARDS NOVEMBER.
>> Mike: YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
IMAGES COMING FROM AFGHANISTAN,
SEEING PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH THE
TROOPS, THANKING THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE AND GIVEN THEM A PAT ON
THE BACK IS THERE A LONG WAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
>> IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
WHETHER DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN,
THIS IS A NONPARTISAN ISSUE, I
WOULD GIVE THE PRESIDENT A
THUMBS UP ON.
WHAT I WOULD NOT GIVE THEM A
THUMBS UP ON IS HOPING HE CAN
ACHIEVE ANY KIND OF PEACE DEAL
WITH A TALIBAN.
YOU CAN'T TRUST THEM, WE'VE SEEN
IT BEFORE AND WHEN WE WALKED
AWAY FROM THE TABLE THEY SAID
WE'RE GOING TO START BOMBING
PEOPLE AND THEY DID JUST THAT
WITH WHAT THEY DID IN KABUL.
I HOPE THERE CAN BE SOME PIECE,
I AGREE IT WILL BE A FEATHER IN
HIS FOREIGN POLICY CAP BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
POSSIBLE.
AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF, VISITING
TROOPS ARE FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM
WHEN THEY ARE AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES, I WILL GIVE HIM A
THUMBS UP ON THAT.
>> Mike: STICKING WITH FOREIGN
POLICY, NORTH KOREA WISHING US A
HAPPY THANKSGIVING UP TO ITS
METRICS, LET'S LISTEN TO THE
JAPANESE PRIME MINISTER.
>> WE HAVEN'T CONFIRMED ANYTHING
FALLING INTO OUR TERRITORY OR
EXCESSIVE ECONOMIC ZONE, THE
FREQUENT LAUNCH OF BALLISTIC
MISSILES IS A SERIOUS CHALLENGE
NOT ONLY FOR JAPAN BUT ALSO THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> ARE THE NORTH KOREANS NOT
GETTING ENOUGH ATTENTION?
>> THE NORTH KOREANS ARE DOING
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE REGARDLESS
OF THE REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND
THE PRESIDENT NOW IS SEEING WHAT
OTHER PRESIDENTS HAVE SEEN IN
THE RECENT DAY OF DEALING WITH,
WHICH IS UNLESS WE REMOVE TROOPS
FROM THE PENINSULA, THEY AREN'T
GOING TO STOP WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT SUPER LAUNCHERS
HERE, THIS IS A LEADER, THIS IS
A NATION NOT TO BE TRUSTED AND
WE ARE SEEING THAT NOT ONLY
TODAY BUT WE HAVE SEEN THAT, WE
CANNOT BE CALLING THIS MAN OR
THIS NATION OUR FRIEND AS THE
PRESIDENT SO FREQUENTLY DOES.
>> THIS IS A RELATIONSHIP THE
PRESIDENT HAS PUT A LOT INTO,
TRYING TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH MOTHER COMMANDERS IN
CHIEF.
>> WHEN HE CAME INTO OFFICE,
THIS WAS THE MOST DIFFICULT AND
DANGEROUS POSITION ON THE
FOREIGN POLICY MENU.
AS HE IS GOING TOWARD THE END OF
HIS FIRST TERM, IT RETURNS TO
BEING, THE MOST DIFFICULT
POSITION HE FACES.
IT'S TRICKY, HE WENT FROM FIRE
AND FURY TO BEAUTIFUL LETTERS,
YOU CAN'T GO BACK TO FIRE AND
FURY.
KIM JONG UN IS NOT AN IDIOT AS
THE PRESIDENT HAS POINTED OUT AS
WELL, HE KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH IMPEACHMENT, HE KNOWS
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
ELECTION AND I THINK HE IS GOING
TO PLAY THE PRESSURE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT, NO ONE
TALKS ABOUT HOW IMPEACHMENT
PLAYS INTO ALL OF THIS, IT MAKES
IT HARD FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
MOVE ON A SERIOUS FOREIGN POLICY
INITIATIVE WITH NORTH KOREA
RIGHT NOW WHEN HE'S BEING
UNDERCUT IN AMERICA.
ALL FOREIGN LEADERS KNOW THIS
BUT IT'S ALSO A HUGE ISSUE
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT THOUGHT HE
COULD ACHIEVE THIS DEAL.
EVERYBODY KNEW NORTH KOREA WAS
GOING TO BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
DENUCLEARIZE AND THEY WANT THE
SANCTIONS REMOVED, THEY WANT
TROOPS TO STOP, STOP HOLDING
EXERCISES IN SOUTH KOREA WHICH
HAS NOT HAPPENED.
THIS IS OUT OF FRUSTRATION THAT
THE NUCLEAR TALKS ARE NOT
RESTARTING COME OF THOSE
SANCTIONS ARE STILL IN PLACE
STILL HURTING NORTH KOREA AND
THOSE JOINT MILITARY EXERCISES
ARE STILL HAPPENING, THEREFORE
KIM JONG UN IS GOING TO KEEP UP
WITH THESE SHORT-RANGE MISSILE
ATTACKS, THIS IS ON THE TWO YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ICBM LAUNCH.
THERE IS GOING TO BE MORE OF
THIS.
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 O
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 M
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 D
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 S
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 T
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 A
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 L
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 S
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 E
>> Mike: TO HOT TOPIC NUMBER 3 N
TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS OF HONG KONG.
>> THE SILENT MAJORITY EXPRESS
THEIR VOICE BUT IT'S AN UPHILL
BATTLE, WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT UNTIL THE DAY WE GET A
FREE ELECTION.
>> HONG KONG QUITE HAPPY THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS PASSED
SEVERAL BILLS STANDING UP FOR
PEOPLE THERE AND GOING AGAINST
BEIJING, THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
INTO LAW, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> THEY WERE CELEBRATING TODAY
IN HONG KONG, AMERICAN FLAGS,
PHOTOS OF TRUMP, EXCITED HE
SIGNED THE BILL, HE DIDN'T HAVE
MUCH OF A CHOICE BECAUSE IT WAS
PASSED NEARLY UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE, THEY COULD
EASILY OVERRIDE A VETO, THAT IS
NOT A BATTLE TRUMP WANTS TO GET
INTO RIGHT NOW, HE DID SIGNAL,
HE WASN'T SURE IF HE'S GOING TO
SIGN THIS IN PART BECAUSE WE ARE
TRYING TO NEGOTIATE THIS BIG
DEAL ON CHINA WITH TRADE, HE
DOES SUPPORT THE PEOPLE OF
HONG KONG.
IT CERTAINLY LOOKS GOOD FOR HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> Mike: WHAT ABOUT THAT?
TRYING TO GET A TRADE DEAL WITH
BEIJING?
>> WHAT SURPRISED ME IS FOR THE
UNCONVENTIONAL PRESIDENT HE IS,
THIS WAS A CONVENTIONAL WAY TO
APPROACH THIS.
SLOW WALKING IT IN THE LAST SIX
DAYS AND WEDNESDAY NIGHT WHEN
MOST OF WASHINGTON WAS ALREADY
TUCKED INTO THANKSGIVING
ANNOUNCING HE WAS SIGNING THIS,
AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE'S
TOO MUCH AT STAKE FOR BOTH
BEIJING AND WASHINGTON TO DO
ANYTHING.
THEY ARE HAVING PORK SHORTAGE, A
DECEMBER 15TH DEADLINE GOING ON
THAT COULD AFFECT THINGS LIKE
TOYS OR iPHONES, AMERICAN
COMPANIES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS AS WELL.
>> LOOK, REGARDLESS OF
WALL STREET OR A TRADE DEAL
WHICH THIS COULD HURT, I'M
SURPRISED THE PRESIDENT CAME TO
THE TABLE DESPITE THE FACT YOU
HAD UNANIMOUS APPROVAL IN THE
SENATE AND ONLY ONE REPUBLICAN
WHO DIDN'T IN THE HOUSE BUILT
FOR THIS, YOU'RE SEEING THIS NOT
ONLY DO OUR ELECTED POLITICIANS
WANT THIS BUT AMERICA WANTS THIS
AND WE HAD TO DO THIS IF WE ARE
GOING TO RING THE BELL OF
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD, THIS IS SOMETHING AS
A LEADER AND THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD THE PRESIDENT HAD TO
DO.